hey guys sounds gonna get sistene and
today we are doing an unboxing of the
new surface book 2 laptop I know what
you're saying Justine aren't you the
biggest Apple fan girl ever yes yes I am
but this laptop is incredible I
absolutely love all of the service lines
by Microsoft my main computer is my
macbook with touch bar it's the US PC
version that came out last year and my
second computer is actually a surface
studio and I love this thing I love it
so much most of my editing I do
everything all on Final Cut but I
started using Premiere a little bit more
and know will not be replacing Final Cut
don't worry and those of you on the
premiere Adobe side I just can't I just
I just can't I'm not ready let's get
into unboxing this what's new in the new
service book 2 is they do look pretty
much exactly like the previous version
of the surface book but there are now
two models this is the 15-inch model and
there's also a 13-inch this also has a
USB C port which I'm extremely excited
about because most of my hard drives
that I use are all USB C thanks to the
MacBook this also has an SD card slot I
know what you're saying
Wow it'll also work with a surface style
which is we huge fan of it took a lot
for this to fully integrate into other
products but this does now work with
premiere which is kind of exciting cause
you can scrub through the timeline a lot
of people I know edit with premiere and
if they send me files I need to at least
be able to know how to change things
around if need be let's start the
unboxing this is the 15 inch surface
book it now comes in two different
models there's the 15 inch and the 13
inch you can customize the smaller
version with an i5 or an i7 and the 15
inch only comes with the i7 processor
you can spec out the ram up to 16 gigs
you can also choose between various hard
drives this is the one terabyte 16 gig
model
I wasn't even gonna do an unboxing this
it was just gonna be a personal thing
for me to open and look at and then I
really did want to share it with you
guys because a lot of you guys give me
such a hard time for being such an apple
fangirl and like yeah I am a fangirl but
guess what I have been so impressed with
a lot of the things that Microsoft has
been doing especially with the service
line like this thing looks great and it
really does spec wise rival the netbooks
and also price why is because these are
priced a little bit higher than I feel
like normal laptops are because not only
as a laptop but it also can be a tablet
you can detach the screen and they have
said that the tablet mode you can use
for five hours and with the screen
attached in laptop mode you can run up
to I quote 17 hours but I'm pretty sure
if I was editing videos or doing normal
things that I would be doing on this
laptop it's not gonna last for 17 hours
it's got some beefy beefy batteries in
it one of the things that is a little
bit different in this model from the
previous version they made this hinge a
little bit more sturdy so that it will
be able to support the larger screen so
this is where you would be charging your
laptop they also added a new USBC port
which I'm extremely excited about this
could be used for data transfer and also
charging and on the other side we have
our C card slot and two USB ports
this rain is huge definitely has some
weight to it it's probably heavier than
my MacBook Pro I would say if I had to
guess let's turn it on while I turn that
on let's see what else we've gotten here
documentation no thank you wow this is
very heavy this has got to be our
charging brick in here
this thing's very heavy its massive this
has a very very strong smell okay it's
just a moment yes I'd like English
please thank you
hi I'm Cortana hi there I'm Cortana no
I'm Cortana or are you Cortana sign in
here but touch a Wi-Fi there and we'll
have your PC ready for all you plan to
do oh girl
yeah I'm a grown-up if you need an
assistive screen restock press the
windows control and enter keys at the
same time to enable narrator how do I
Shh okay enough intro let's dig in well
while you're doing that surface style I
thought this was a little sticky tab I
didn't think that it popped the whole
back of it off please hold
I thought that peeled this little sticky
back off let us know if this computer is
owned by your work or school me it's
yours it's mine follow these
instructions and I'll meet you back here
once we're done yes thank you use
Windows hello to unlock your PC quick as
a wink with just your face no wink
required want to set that up now sure
hold still for a second okay we need to
learn to recognize you learn me Cortana
is super pleasant few more things
polished up for you and windows will be
all yours looking forward to helping out
me too let's set this up so this is a
little sticky tab that you pull off just
like that and that's what I thought I
was pulling off earlier
so right here is the little eject button
when you press this it prepares your
device before come here for tablet mode
this is really it's actually quite light
do you want to such a talent mode yes
and to attach it back on we just do that
same action
voila do you want to exit tablet mode
yes obviously switching to tablet mode
will save your battery when you're using
it in tablet mode but I feel like I like
having it ask me because maybe I'm not
ready making sure it's me does have the
facial recognition which is kind of
great I use that pretty often on my
surface studio which I talked about very
very often especially with the new
implementation of face ID on the new
iPhone I will say one of the things that
I'm pretty excited about is the SD card
slot I know as crazy and simple as it is
I'm excited about it because I go to a
lot of shoots and I shoot a lot of video
and a lot of times I like bringing the
least amount of things as possible so
before I'd have to bring my MacBook
separate hard drives dongles SD cards
all of these things that try to make
that work so now I can just bring this
in a hard drive and I'm good to go I
also don't like bringing my main
computer that I do all of my work on my
editing and everything because I've so
much information on that that I'm always
so afraid that I'm gonna leave it
somewhere it's gonna get stolen now that
I'm slowly learning Premiere - I'll
still be able to do a little bit of
editing on the go with this but man I
really love Final Cut okay I love it so
much at this point it would take me so
much time to relearn everything and to
be as fast as I am and Final Cut and I
was so slow and premier that that time
wasted is very very valuable especially
when it comes to editing and posting
videos for you guys to another stylist
does not come with a pen so I need my
stylus separate I guess so
all right hello hello mr. sounds pretty
awesome we just gonna attach that like
so
there it is am I'm doing all of the work
that I did you can choose between
several different things especially in
this app there aren't as many options
but depending upon which app you have
open this dial will do various things so
here we go we can zoom it seems uma zoom
can adjust the volume as you can see
right there the little dial this thing's
pretty awesome let me know if you guys
would like me to make a follow-up video
maybe like a day in the life with the
surface book I don't know I've never
really done one of those before but I
thought maybe it could be really fun
maybe to see how I would use this over
my Mac and what I do with my Mac maybe
just a day in the life with my gadgets
what I don't know I'm not sure well see
you guys in my next video thank you so
much for watching leave me some comments
below and let me know if there's
anything else you would like to see me
make in the future and that's it I'm
gonna go I don't know so I see you later
[Music]
[Applause]